New Zealand calls state of emergency over
torrential flooding | DW News
New Zealand's military has been called in
to help evacuate hundreds of people caught
in flooding in the country's South Island.
A state of emergency has been declared in
the Canterbury region that surrounds the city
of Christchurch.
As much as 40 centimeters of rain has fallen
in the area over the last two days.
Meteorologists say that in some areas, that's
more than the entire rainfall so far this
year.
The extent of the flooding.
Houses marooned by water.
Roads impassable -
This one left with a gaping hole.
And rivers have turned into lakes.
"Well, I went to bed about 10 o'clock last
night and there was not a sign of the river.
Get up at 6 o'clock this morning and it's
gone, half of the farm is underwater."
The Canterbury region on New Zealand's South
Island is a farming hub.
But the deluge of rain is making work hard
- even if some are putting on a brave face.
"Just carried on, just carried on.
Can't worry about it.
You know you just got to pour water on or
just farm to the conditions."
But conditions have left some in extreme danger.
On Sunday, this man was airlifted to safety
after becoming trapped in flood water.
"It has been a really delicate rescue, very
lucky.
We tried a rescue helicopter earlier, but
they couldn't get through because of the weather,
so it's just been a really good outcome for
everybody and well done to the chopper crew."
Here, rescue workers are trying to reach a
car that's fallen down the cliff just above
the raging river.
Hundreds of people have been evacuated from
their homes.
Authorities have now declared a state of emergency
with more rain expected.